y la fiscalía de cuba advirtió que los
promotores de la marcha pueden ser
juzgados y que se exponen a penas de
cárcel cuál es la respuesta de
archipiélago a esa advertencia que
esperan ustedes que pase a partir de
esta nueva convocatoria
primero nosotros angela bueno un placer
estar acá nosotros desconocemos
continuando esencia de la fiesta día les
conocemos pues la prohibición de esta
marcha en primer lugar porque es ilegal
y sants como anticonstitucional esta
prohibición nosotros estamos pidiendo
únicamente las garantías y los
intendentes municipales nos respondieron
precisamente con interpretaciones de la
constitución y la prohibición de esta
magia se va se basa en lo que ellos
creen que somos nosotros y lo que es
quieren decirle a las personas acá en
cuba que somos nosotros acusándolas de
mercenarios de terroristas entonces qué
podemos esperar podemos esperar de
presiones en la medida en la que el
mundo gira los ojos para cubas podremos
esperar menos depresión
precisamente previo a estas
manifestaciones para el 15 han recibido
presiones para no salir a manifestar
todo el tiempo todo el tiempo la
intención es precisamente que nosotros
no salgamos a manifestarlo pero además
que las personas que nos apoyen tampoco
salgan a manifestarse las situaciones no
pagan situaciones por parte de la
policía en definitiva son con la policía
política que son los condenas del
departamento de la seguridad del estado
acá en cuba amedrentamientos actos del
repudio como es el caso del inder garcía
incluso actos que son hasta ridículos
pero que están relacionados con la
religión afrocubana como lo que hicieron
ayunar garcía es principal promotor de
esta más bueno y entre tanto que ha
pasado con los procesados del 11 de
julio en que van las denuncias de
detenciones arbitrarias y de torturas
bueno con esas personas estamos
implementando nos en estos momentos la
imposición de penas de hasta 25 años de
relación de libertad simplemente por
salir a manifestarse al 11 de julio de
imputan delitos que son totalmente
mentiras como desorden público y
desacato es terrible terrible lo que
está pasando con estas personas y es un
poco también para anexionar o sea para
decirles es parte de toda esta
estrategia de comunicación que
establecido comiendo jugar para contarle
a las personas es lo que les puede pasar
si ellos saben que es toda una campaña
de miedo y terror lo que están
desarrollando